protesters lying in the road try to stop
what opposition mps have tried to foil
in the commons and bishops have written
a letter to a newspaper to describe as
shameful
but while vans did take asylum seekers
from their detention center in heathrow
to an mod air base in wheelchair to be
flown on this aircraft to rwanda
lawyers would eventually stop it from
taking off
earlier the prime minister
justified the policy
what is your alternative
to
people being shipped across the channel
in very frail unseaworthy dinghies
risking their lives and undermining the
rule of law what's your alternative we
think it's a sensible partnership we've
set up with rwanda yes it may take a
while uh to to get working properly but
doesn't mean we're not going to keep
going
earlier last-ditch legal pleas at the
high court seemed desperate iraqi zaheer
not his real name was one of those
scheduled to get on the flight and spoke
to me from his detention center
and as the vans arrived at boscom down
airbase in wiltshire news emerged that
zaheer had won an injunction to keep him
off the aircraft and another iraqis
departure was being halted by the
european court of human rights
the european court says it only grants
such requests in exceptional cases where
the applicant would otherwise face a
real risk of irreversible harm and the
campaign group care for cali which is
trying to stop these asylum seekers
heading down this runway to rwanda so
this opens up the opportunity for other
claims but all this while the clock is
ticking
meanwhile in kent another group of
migrants were rescued from a dangerous
crossing sky news counted around 260
people arriving in dover tuesday morning
the government wants to send a signal
that these desperate trips across the
channel could be a one-way ferry to
rwanda
some are too young to understand any of
it
others don't want to believe it
no rwanda
but as the plane sat on the tarmac it
emerged rulings by judges both in the uk
and the eu meant that no one could be
deported the home secretary said she was
disappointed but not deterred and
preparation for the next flight begins
now
jason farrell sky news